Welcome to this
episode of UXD, where
we will talk about how
to create compelling user
experiences that
will effectively
engage your users
by understanding how
visual attention
and memory work.
The second episode of
the two-part series
is all about
understanding memory.
Please watch the first
part if you haven't already
to learn more about
visual attention.
I'm your host, Nazmul
Idris, a developer
advocate passionate
about design and mobile.
In this episode, I'll
talk about a few things
that are related to
human memory and how
they can be used to create
engaging experiences that
really capture your
user's attention.
Both attention and memory
are finite resources,
and these resources
are further taxed
if we have an environment
that provides us
with a lot of stimulus,
like let's say,
a busy airport, or
driving in heavy traffic,
or being in a loud restaurant
with lot of people.
Now, working memory is
a very limited resource,
which means that we can only
keep so many things in our head
before we forget them
in the short term.
For example, when was the last
time this happened to you?
Let's say, you walked to the
fridge to get something to eat,
and by the time
you've gotten there,
you've forgotten what
you wanted to eat.
Now, people can't
really multitask either,
since we just single
task and incur
really expensive
context-switching costs.
So it's really important to
respect these limitations
in order to deliver user
experiences that will not just
cause the user to tune
out because your app is
overwhelming their
attention and their memory.
So let's start with
primacy and recency.
Let's say that you have a long
list of stuff to remember.
You probably remember stuff
at the very top, which
is called primacy, and
stuff at the very end, which
is called recency.
So how can you use
this in practice?
Let's say that you
have to present
the user with a
list of information.
Make sure to put the
most important stuff
at the very top of the list
and other important stuff
at the very bottom.
And less important stuff should
go somewhere in the middle.
Similarly, if you've
got a list of actions
that you have to present
a user with in a menu,
you should follow
this idea, as well.
The most important actions go to
the very top or the very bottom
of the menu with less important
actions in the middle.
Now, this also
applies to content
that you're creating for
consumption on the web
and on mobile.
Make sure that you put
the really important stuff
on the top and the bottom.
This will ensure that
you're leveraging
the way our memory
naturally works in order
to get the user's attention.
Now, another aspect of memory
is recall versus recognition.
What am I talking about?
Well, recall is having
to retrieve something
from memory, which is actually
much more difficult for people
than recognition.
So generally it's a bad
idea to require a user
to recall something
in an application.
And it's best to replace it with
recognition wherever possible.
For example, how
many times have you
been frustrated when you were
presented with a login dialogue
or form that required
you to recall
both your username and password?
Here's a great example
of using recognition
rather than recall used
for login or authorization.
It's from the Google application
specific password generator web
app.
In this example, it's
not asking the user
to remember a
username and password.
Rather they can just copy and
paste this generated password
into another app
rather than having
to remember this stuff
and type it in manually.
Another best practice
around recall
is to pre-populate fields
that users have already
entered information into as they
flow between connected screens.
A great example of this
is filling up long forms
with lots of data that
has to be typed in.
For example, when you're
applying for a credit card
or creating, let's say,
a billing and shipping
profile for an
e-commerce site, there
can be a multi-step flow to
complete the process where
you have to fill out three
or four forms in succession.
Now, don't make the
user recall stuff
they've already filled
out earlier in the form
because this puts high
cognitive load on them.
We have limited
short-term memory,
and this is one of the
things that will tax it.
Pre-populate information
that's already been provided,
or provide a link to
this information when
you can and your users
will appreciate you for it.
Still don't think that it's a
big deal to fill out big forms?
Well, shopping carts have an
average of 70% abandonment rate
because there's
too much friction
to fill out account
creation, shipping, billing,
and payment form information.
Fixing these issues aren't
just good for the user,
but they're also great
for the bottom line.
And ideally, if you
can totally bypass
asking a user to fill out
information in the form,
that's even better.
For example, if you
use things like Sign
in with Google and
Google Wallet where
you can remove large chunks of
friction from your apps user
experience by simply
using information
that you need that the user has
already entered somewhere else,
that's a good thing.
Another example of using
recognition rather than recall
can be seen on some
online banking sites.
The idea is that you
select a picture when
you create an
account, and you're
the only one that knows what
picture you've selected.
Then when you try to log
in to the site again,
it will just show
you this picture.
This process just asks
you to recognize a picture
and not select it from memory.
And it lets you know that
this is indeed your account.
This is to confirm that you're
not logging into a phishing
site, because they
wouldn't have this picture
and instead they would ask
you to input a lot of data
and not just display it.
Now, another thing
that's related
to memory which is
really important
is something called
change aversion.
This is a phenomenon
that causes you
to hate, at first,
any significant change
in the UI of your favorite
application or exterior
styling of your favorite car.
It's different than
what you remember.
This is totally natural
and cannot be avoided,
but it's possible to
mitigate its effects.
This QR code links to an awesome
article in the Google Ventures
Library written by user
researcher Aaron Sedley.
Please read it in detail.
And it covers various
tactics that you
can use to mitigate the negative
effects of change version.
Ideally, it's important to
gradually introduce changes
so the user cannot
perceive a big,
drastic change all at once.
So if you look at the
evolution of the Porsche 911,
for example, they've
made minor changes
to a car that was first
created in the late '60s.
And people still get
bent out of shape
with every incremental
change that they make.
So it's gradual change made
over 40 years happened too fast?
All kidding aside, things
move much faster in software,
especially on mobile.
So it's best to gradually
introduce changes and give
users a heads-up if there's
big changes that are coming.
And if possible, even
give them the ability
to toggle between
old and new versions,
or even provide vestigial
remains of the old UI
as they're being
migrated to the new one.
And then gradually remove
functionality from the old one.
Now, you can play with
change aversion in your app
as it evolves.
For example, if you want to
hide changes that you're making,
you can actually make
very gradual changes
between every
release of your app.
On mobile apps, this is
harder to do than on web apps.
On the web, you could just
make a few just-noticeable
differences daily
over a period of days,
and nobody will
probably even notice.
On the other hand, if you
want to feature a big change,
if you want to
highlight it, then you
can never change
aversion to your benefit.
To make an impact to an
existing user for app,
you can make changes that
are greater than those which
are just-noticeable
differences, and this
will captivate their attention.
So depending on how you
use change aversion,
you can hide or feature
changes in your app.
While people have
change aversion,
there's another effect called
the mere-repeated-exposure
effect, which is a
way to overcome this.
Mere exposure is
a phenomenon where
if someone is merely exposed to
something that they may or may
not like repeatedly,
then over time
they will tend to develop
a preference for it
simply because they've
become familiar with it.
And this is also called
the familiarity principle.
This is essentially
how people form ideas
around what is intuitive
in a user interface.
What a user means when they say
a user interface is intuitive
is that they're familiar
with it and that it's
matched their expectations
based on their prior experience
with software.
This is why it's so important
to follow conventions.
However, this is
also how conventions
are formed in the first place.
For example, when Android moved
from Gingerbread to Ice Cream
Sandwich, that was
a radical departure
in the design language,
which many people
had change aversion to.
However, today now that people
are used to Ice Cream Sandwich,
Gingerbread-style apps just
look dated and out of place.
These are all important
things for you
to keep in mind as you decide
when to adopt new design
languages and
platform capabilities,
especially around mobile
since it evolves so rapidly.
That's all the
time we have today.
If you haven't already,
please be sure to join our UX
community on Google+.
It's a place where we can
continue this discussion,
and you can meet others who
are just as passionate about UX
as you are.
Thanks for watching
and good-bye.